les mineurs et tmh
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi la justice française en fête
refuse de de s'appliquer
qu'est ce que ça cache est ce que c'est
parce que c'est des militaires est parce
qu est-ce que c'est parce que ça donne
un scandale d'état
parce qu'on a une enfant qui a été violé
par vingt militaires dans son pays
et on a une justice on a un pays qui
refuse de lui de le reconnaître
voilà c'est ça le scandale jeudi
c'est une enfant qui était face à une
vingtaine de pompiers
donc la contrainte elle est évidente et
même lorsqu'on parle d'une enfant de 13
ans à la justice est toujours incapable
de se rendre compte que on n'est pas
dans un rapport de force équitable et
que julie quand les violets par vingt
pompiers
elle est violée sous contrainte et
qu'elle n'a pas pu consentir à n'a pas
pu accepter ces viols puisqu'elle était
une enfant
[Musique]
tu peux dire
on n'est pas à une justice qui ignore
les violences sexuelles et sexistes et
donc forcément les droits des femmes et
des enfants se retrouvent impactés
andré notre